der Tag vor dem alle gewarnt haben
beginnt mit einer furchterregenden
[Musik]
Nachricht China überfällt Taiwan
Experten haben dieses Kriegsszenario
bereits vorgezeichnet sie prophezeien
eine Invasion durch China Bombardements
die Taiwans Marine und Luftwaffe
zerstören Zeus chinesische Soldaten die
die Straße von Taiwan
überqueren seit langem hat China mit der
Annexion
gedroht tun sie nicht so als ob Taiwan
nicht zu China gehört ich glaube das
sehen wir sehr klar dass gerade sich
Staaten zusammentun die die Weltkarte
auch neu sortieren wollen es wäre ein
Krieg der weit weg erscheint doch er
hätte katastrophale Folgen für
Deutschland wir sind erpressbar ja wir
hätten Versorgungsengpässe und wir
hätten Massenarbeitslosigkeit ein
Wegfallen der Märkte würde beiden
Volkswirtschaften schwer schwer Schaden
kaum ein Land hat sich so abhängig
gemacht von und
China das ist der Moment in dem man aus
deutscher Perspektive innhalten muss und
sagen muss wollen wir das wirklich noch
so denn wir sind verwundbar wie konnte
es so weit kommen wir suchen nach
Ursachen und Antworten in China in
Deutschland und in Taiwan gibt es einen
Weg aus der
[Musik]
Abhängigkeit
es gibt viele Warnungen dass etwas
schiefläuft dass die Abhängigkeit von
China gefährlich wird für uns in
Deutschland eine Warnung ist die
Geschichte des sechsjährigen Anton aus
Berlin und seines Arztes Malik bötcher
der Anton seit langem kennt das ist
einer gewesen der nie richtig krank wird
und wenn er Schnupfen hatte und Fieber
hatte ist er trotzdem auf Spielplatz
spielen gewesen Anfang Mai bekommt Anton
einen schweren Infekt ein Fernsehteam
dreht er gerade in der Praxis und filmt
seinen Besuch beim Arzt wir haben ihn
untersucht haben gesehen dass er eine
Bronchitis mit Übergang zur
tatsächlichen Pneumonie hat und dann
haben wir uns entschieden antibiotische
Therapie zu Beginen und diese
Antibiotika waren in der Apotheke auch
erstmal lieferbar
allerdings in zu geringer Menge in zu
geringer
Dosis es ist nicht viel was über unser
Leben
entscheidet eine kleine Tablette kann es
sein wenn sie da ist denkt man nicht
darüber nach wenn sie fehlt oder wie bei
Anton zu wenig davon da ist wird es
gefährlich der Grund für den Mangel
China liefert zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht
genug Cephalosporine also Antibiotika
und ohne China geht es nicht also wenn
die Chinesen uns da nichts mehr abgeben
in anführungstriche dann dann fehlen uns
zephalosporine und insbesondere für
schwere Infektionen sind zephalosporine
sehr sehr wichtig das heißt Menschen
werden sterben
deswegen es gibt niemanden der dir sagt
macht dir keine Sorgen bald werden die
Antibiotiker wieder lieferbar sein der
Mangel wird zum Normalfall dann der
Mangel wird zum Normalfall bötcher
versucht die Abhängigkeit von China in
diesem Fall zu umgehen indem er Anton
mit einer geringeren Dosis behandelt
doch das klappt nicht kurz nach diesen
Aufnahmen muss Anton mit einer schweren
Lungenentzündung ins
Krankenhaus abhängig zu sein von China
das hat in Deutschland lange kaum
jemanden
besorgt das Verhältnis war so
unproblematisch dass wir nie uns Sorgen
darüber machen müssten dass das gegen
uns verwendet werden könnte inzwischen
ist es aber so wir sehen das China hat
sich geändert deswegen müssen wir uns
verändern wie sehr sich China verändert
hat zeigt sich Mitte Oktober bei der
seidenstraßenkonferenz in Peking
shiining Seite an Seite mit einem Mann
der mit internationalem Haftbefehl
gesucht wird Wladimir Putin sein
brutaler Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
ist für Chi kein Grund Abstand zu nehmen
im
Gegenteil all diese äußeren Faktoren
sind gemeinsame Bedrohungen und sie
stärken die russischchinesische
Zusammenarbeit wir müssen draußen
bleiben und die Eröffnungsfeier wie fast
alle westlichen Medien auf drei
Bildschirmen im Pressezentrum verfolgen
für Chi ist die Seidenstraße ein
Instrument zur Ausdehnung von Chinas
Macht und
Einfluss China verspricht Geschenke und
verlangt Gefolgschaft wer sich
dementzieht dem droht hi
undverblümt wer die Entwicklung anderer
Staaten als Bedrohung betrachtet und
wirtschaftliche Verflechtungen als ein
Risiko lebt nicht besser und treibt
seine eigene Entwicklung nicht voran
mit Putin teilt ch eine
großmachtfantasie die dem eigenen Reich
andere Länder einverleiben will was für
Putin die Ukraine ist für Chi
Taiwan Chis ziel ist es Taiwan ins
Mutterland zurückzuholen im Zweifel auch
mit Gewalt ein Szenario das viele Jahre
so undenkbar war wie ein Krieg mitten in
Europa aber seit dem russischen Überfall
auf die Ukraine ist auch eine Invasion
Taiwans in den Bereich des Möglichen
gerückt ein Krieg der weit über die
indopazifikreion hinausgehen würde der
die USA Japan und ihre westlichen
Verbündeten mit hineinziehen würde aber
auch Chinas Verbündete allen voran
Nordkorea und Russland mit auf den Plan
rufen
würde wir sind mit einem
Weltkriegsszenario konfrontiert und
Russland könnte die Gunst der Stunde
nutzen da die Amerikaner dann im Pazifik
gebunden sind auch Europa auch NATO
Territorium im Zweifelsfall auch
Deutschland anzugreifen wir könnten uns
unmittelbar im Krieg
wiederfinden wie unmissverständlich
ernst es China ist Taiwan dem Mutterland
einzuverleiben zeigen hunderte Kampfjets
Bombe militärdrohnen und Kriegsschiffe
der Volksbefreiungsarmee in der Straße
von
Taiwan 2022 zählten Experten 1700
chinesische Flüge in Taiwans
luftverteidigungszone in diesem Jahr sei
diese Zahl bereits
übertroffen immer wieder probt China den
Einmarsch in die demokratisch regierte
Insel und lässt die eigenen Bürger und
die Welt im Staatsfernsehen dabei
zusehen eine Demonstration der Macht wir
treffen victtor GA Vizepräsident des
Center for China and globalization und
inoffizielles sprachr der
kommunistischen parte zum
Interview gib der Taiwan Konflikt bald
eskaliert die Position Chinas ist sehr
klar es gibt nur ein China Taiwan ist
Teil Chinas und die Regierung der
Volksrepublik China ist die einzige
legitime Vertreterin Chinas tun sie
nicht so als ob sie diesen Grundpfeiler
der heutigen internationalen Ordnung
nicht kennen würden tun sie nicht so als
ob Taiwan nicht Teil Chinas
wäreining hat die sogenannte
wiederereinigung mit Taiwan zur
Chefsache erklärt die Schuldigen für
eine mögliche militärische Eskalation
hat China bereits ausgemacht sie
befinden sich in den USA und in
[Musik]
Taiwan in taipe am Nationalheiligtum der
merther gedenken sie der Opfer des
Bürgerkriegs als kommunistische und
republikanische Chinesen sich
gegenseitig
töteten über allen hier liegt die es
bald noch mehr werden könnten angesichts
der permanenten Drohungen seines
übergroßen Bruders rüstet der kleine
demokratische Inselstaat massiv
auf der Verteidigungshaushalt stieg
allein in diesem Jahr um 14% auf einen
neuen Höchstwert gerade erst wurde das
erste eigene U-Boot
fertiggestellt die USA sollen die
Luftwaffe mit
F16
abr Panzer wurden bereits
bestellt wir werden in Taiwans
Präsidentenpalast empfangen vom Chef des
Nationalen
Sicherheitsrats Wellington cou hat die
anspruchsvolle Aufgabe seine Insel vor
der Bedrohung durch China zu
schützen China strebt die Vereinigung
mit dem taiwanesischen Territorium an
und macht kein he daraus dass es dies
auf jede erdenkliche Art und Weise
umsetzen wird aber die Taiwan haben ein
sehr tiefes Verständnis davon dass
Diktatur und Demokratie nicht
miteinander vereinbar
sind seitdem die republikanischen
Truppen
1949 vor den Kommunisten hierher flohen
fordert China die Rückkehr der in seinen
Augen abtrünnigen Insel
93% der Taiwaner aber lehnen das ab die
meisten von ihnen vertrauen darauf dass
ihre Regierung alles Nötige tun wird um
sie zu schützen manchen aber reicht das
nicht
guten Tag ich bin Chang ich bin vor
einem halben Jahr aus der Ukraine
zurückgekommen der 52jährige ist
eigentlich Reiseleiter für Japan doch
schon im März 2022 entschied er sich
diesmal an die Front zu
reisen wir wollen Taiwan etwas Zeit
verschaffen wenn die Ukraine fällt dann
wird es vielleicht unser Taiwan
nstesffen wir der ukra
k zu kämpfen werden wir auch eine Minute
mehr Sicherheit für Taiwan
haben das ist die AK47 mit der ich in
der Ukraine gekämpft
habe in einem Militärverein in taipe
bewahrtang nun die Ausrüstung auf die er
als Mitglied der internationalen Legion
in der Ukraine erhalten
[Musik]
hat ukrainische Nationalflagge wenn man
überlebt darf man sie als Souvenir nach
Hause mitnehmen wenn man stirbt wird sie
über den SAG
gelegt ein Soldat aus Taiwan ist in der
Ukraine gefallen trotzdem hatang nach
acht Monaten Einsatz vor allem eines
mitgebracht
[Musik]
Mut bevor ich in die Ukraine ging wusste
ich nicht ob wir den Chinesen D Tage D
Wochen oder dre Monate lang Widerstand
leisten können
aber seitdem ich dort gekämpft habe
denke ich wenn Deutschland Frankreich
Großbritannien und die Vereinigten
Staaten bereit sind Taiwan mit Waffen zu
unterstützen so wie sie die Ukraine
unterstützen dann können wir China
besiegen noch mehr Andenken und
Ausrüstungsgegenstände hatang
mitgebracht etwa ein in seinen Augen dem
taiwanischen weit überlegenes erste
hilfeset
juang trainiert für den Fall dass
Chinesen wieder gegen Chinesen kämpfen
am Abend ist er verabredet mit anderen
denen es genauso
geht in der Herbstsonne von München
wirkt das weit weg bei der
Automobilausstellung soll Volkswagens
auftritt so majestätisch wirken wie E
und je aber etwas ist anders etwas wirkt
auch hier
bedrohlich Volkswagens Elektroautos
verkaufen sich schlecht in China den
wichtigsten Automarkt der Welt die
ehemalige königsmarke in China wird
gerade
tront von Marken aus China eine BYD hat
sich direkt gegenüber aufgebaut es wirkt
wie ein Duell auf Münchens
prachtbolvar für Volkswagen geht es
dabei um alles kein anderer Konzern in
Deutschland ist so abhängig vom Geschäft
in China das chinesische E-Autos davon
zuziehen drohen ist für Volkswagen
lebensgefährlich für Chinas Bauer
dagegen eine Genugtung also wir bieten
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anderes als
die deutsche Anbieter nämlich in China
ist das sehr wichtig eine
digitale Funktionalität im
Auto ich glaube die haben gar nicht an
der Elektromobilität geglaubt ist
fxwagen oder GM sie waren dominiert aber
wenn sie heutage sehen äh vor allem über
die Elektromobilität der die chinesische
Autohersteller sind da über
60% der MAK der Anteil Peter Notter zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch BMW Vertriebsvorstand
inspiziert Chinas
E-Autos legendär war früher die Arroganz
deutscher Automanager gegenüber
chinesischen Modellen heute hgern die
Autobosse reihenweise herbei um die
Chinesen zu studieren und eigene
Versäumnisse auch Wolfgang porche der
mächtige VW Eigner und im Schlepptau mit
dabei vwchef Oliver
Blume wir sind nach wie vor in China das
stärkste Automobilunternehmen und für
uns ist es jetzt ganz entscheidend dass
uns die Transformation in die
Elektromobilität gelingt wenn die
Chinesen sagen deutsche Autos sind
uncool dann kaufe ich mir lieber ein BYD
also dann wird vielleicht VW nur noch
was weiß ich 20 oder 30% von sein Profit
aus China bekommen das wä natürlich für
Wolfsburg eine Katastrophe im großen
mess München nimmt eine alarmierte
deutschlandag Aufstellung Kanzler neben
autobossen Scholz eilt nach München eilt
Volkswagen und Co zuuhilfe durch den
Angriff aus China Gerät etwas ins
Rutschen Gewinne der deutschen Marken
und damit auch hunderttausende
Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland die
mobilitätswende ist eine große Aufgabe
aber sie ist eine Teamaufgabe und ich
komme heute hier zu ihnen als
überzeugtes Mitglied dieses Teams
das Team kämpft gegen einen großen
Gegner Chinas e-Autos sind günstig weil
Peking sie offenbar unfair
subventioniert währen könnte sich
Deutschland mit europaweiten Strafzöllen
das ist ein bisschen die Idee der
chinaastategie level playing viel zu
schaffen und sagen ihr schützt eure
Märkte ihr macht Subvention wir schützen
unsere Märkte dann vor euren Produkten
gleiches Recht für alle wir lassen uns
nicht aus dem Spielfeld schopsen das
sind ganz klassische Mittel die wir
haben hier in Europa in unserer
Werkzeugkasten mit dem wir operieren
können diesen Werkzeugkasten nicht zu
nutzen zu einem Zeitpunkt wo wir sehen
können dass die
ja die Menge und der Preis der
Elektroautos die wir in die Märkte
drängen sehen etwas ist was eine
strukturelle Verschiebung des Marktes
nach sich ziehen wird das wäre das wäre
Wahnsinn aber wird Deutschland sich
trauen wird Europa einen harten
konfliktwagen mit China das ist genau
plötzlich passiert noch etwas
anderes eine
die Party sei vorbei verkündet
Greenpeace und Leibwächter schirman
Scholz
ab es geht ums Klima aber was wenn hier
noch eine ganz andere Party zu Ende geht
ein ganzer Industriezweig Deutschlands
Wirtschaftsmodell der Handel mit China
das war lange eine Party einen
strategischen Partner nannte Angela
Merkel Peking
dasziputsch Ingenieurskunst China billig
Ware wir dachten in einem autoritären
Staat gibt es nicht die Möglichkeiten zu
Freiheit und zu Kreativität wie das in
der Demokratie ist und deswegen können
wir eigentlich problemlos Handel mit
China betreiben weil China wird zwar
immer versuchen das nachzubauen was wir
Ihnen was wir dorthin exportieren aber
sie werden immer einen Schritt hinter
uns sein weil Chinesen zwar fleißig sind
aber sie gehorchen haben keine Ideen das
war das Klischee ganz genau das war ein
wahnsinniger Irrtum denn das führte
einfach dazu dass China aufgeholt und in
einigen Fällen überholt hat für
Deutschlands Wirtschaftsbosse war der
chinahandel ein höchst profitables
Geschenk nun wird er zur Gefahr weil
China aufgeholt ja in manchen Bereichen
überholt hat wir sind an ein Punkt
angekommen wo man merkt dass sich das
die Balance verschiebt die Importe aus
China nehmen zu unsere Exporte nach
China nehmen ab das wirtschaftliche
Gleichgewicht verschiebt sich hin zu
China und das ist der Moment in dem man
aus deutscher Perspektive innerhalten
muss und sagen muss wollen wir das
wirklich noch so das deutsche
Geschäftsmodell ist erledigt und das
beruht aus ihrer Sicht worauf na ja das
beruht darauf dass wir billige
Vorprodukte aus China importieren
billiges Gas aus
Russland Geschäfte damit machen aus der
ganzen Welt und die Amerikaner bezahlen
für unsere Sicherheit so das ist jetzt
definitiv zu
Ende wie abhängig wir von globalen
Lieferketten sind haben Corona und
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine uns
vorgeführt aber unsere Abhängigkeit von
China ist in Wahrheit noch viel größer
zuständig für Deutschlands Handel ist
der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister welche Lehren
hat Robert habbeck gezogen wir hatten
55% gasabhängigkeit und wir haben es
gerade so geschafft dass die
Volkswirtschaft weiterlufen konnte 90
hätten wir nicht geschafft das wä nicht
möglich gewesen 55 konnten wir ersetzen
mit hoher Inflation mit mit hohen
Preisen mit einer zwar abgewehrten
tiefen Wirtschaftskrise aber mit einer
Schwäche Periode die sich durch dieses
ganze Jahr durchzieht 90 hätte uns die
Füße weggezogen 90% so hoch ist unsere
Abhängigkeit von China z.B bei manchen
Medikamenten oder Seltenen Erden wenn es
zu einer Konfrontation mit Taiwan kommt
dann werden die Beziehung zwischen
Deutschland und China sich über Nacht
komplett
verändern ein solcher Angriffskrieg
hätte Sanktionen gegen China zur Folge
und die wichtigste Handelsroute der Welt
würde abreißen allein der direkte Handel
mit China kostet uns wahrscheinlich 1
Million Arbeitsplätze wenn wir uns da
von heute auf morgen loslösen müssen
aber das ist eben nicht alles denn durch
die Straße von Taiwan wird etwa ein
Drittel bis die Hälfte des globalen
Warenhandels verschifft das heißt auch
das würde ja alles hier nicht mehr
ankommen das heißt wir hätten
Versorgungsengpässe und wir hätten
Massenarbeitslosigkeit das will sich
wirklich niemand ausmalen
die Bundesregierung hat inzwischen eine
chinastategie beschlossen das Ziel heißt
die risking weniger Chin Risiko weniger
China Naivität aber was bedeutet das wie
könnte es
klappen taiwan hat sich schon früh
überlegt wie es sich absichern kann sein
ass ist die
Halbleiterindustrie eines der
wertvollsten Unternehmen der Welt TSMC
外的口 würde Taiwans Außenhandel
unterbrochen dann wäre das eine große
Katastrophe nicht nur für Taiwan sondern
für die ganze Welt denn Taiwan steht für
60% der weltweiten Produktion von
halbleitern導體佔全世界的這個超過60%的供應量 SMC die
Taiwan Semiconductor manufacturing
company hat ihrem Erfolgsprodukt
Halbleiter ein Museum
gewidmet die winzigen Chips stecken in
Kühlschränken Autos und Handys auf der
ganzen Welt der Erfolg einer
jahrzehntelang verfolgten
Industriepolitik in der Vergangenheit
hat TSMC wie alle anderen auf die Kosten
geschielt und viel in china investiert
doch früher als bei uns begann man um zu
denken und auf die risking zu
setzen陸 das Festland ist immer häufiger
unser Konkurrent in der Folge sind
Taiwans Investitionen in Festland China
in den letzten 14 Jahren nach und nach
zurückgegangen im Jahr 2020 haben auch
die letzten taiwanesischen Unternehmen
verstanden dass die Produktionskosten
nicht mehr der wichtigste Faktor eines
Unternehmens sind sondern dass sie
geopolitische erwegungen und
Risikostreuung in Betracht ziehen
müssen im Museum von TSMC wird an die
sieben Väter der Elektroindustrie
erinnert Manager und
Regierungsmitglieder die sich vor fast
50 Jahren in einer Sojamilch snackbude
zusammensetzten und eine weitreichende
Entscheidung trafen chrisy ist
Wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin sie kennt
TSMC genau sie nimmt uns mit wir wählen
zwischen Sojamilch warm oder Kal süß
oder salzig Proteine die auch die
Gründerväter der taiwanischen
Elektroindustrie zu sich genommen haben
damals sie haben beschlossen dass wir
unsere Kompetenz auf ein Produkt
konzentrieren sollten und dass wir etwas
entwickeln sollten das nicht einfach von
unseren Nachbarländern kopiert werden
kan Unterstützung und ging voll auf
heute ist die ganze Welt von Taiwans
Halbleitern abhängig der
Produktionsprozess einzigartig
ausgefallt es ist sehr ironisch aber
selbst wenn die Chinesen TSMC erobern
würden bekämen sie nur die Fabrik das
Gebäude denn die Leute haben ja Beine
und die meisten Ingenieure eine
Greencard die können einfach in die USA
gehen was sie im Kern ausmacht würde
nicht weiter
funktionieren weder China noch der Rest
der Welt kann es sich leisten wenn der
Nachschub an Halbleitern ausfällt also
wird China sich gut überlegen ob es
Taiwan wirklich angreift und die
internationale Gemeinschaft wird alles
versuchen um einen Krieg um Taiwan zu
verhindern und nicht nur das Taiwans
Strategie hat weitreichende Einflüsse
auf den Welthandel
und auf Europa sagt matie duel einer der
führenden Taiwan
Experten ich denke das ist praktiziertes
die risking also Risikominimierung von
Taiwan das heißt nicht dass
Globalisierung völlig tot ist ich denke
wir haben es mit einem gewissen Grad an
deglobalisierung zu tun aber wir bleiben
in der Welt der gegenseitigen
Abhängigkeiten der Verknüpfung von
Lieferketten das bleibt aber es gibt
immer mehr Ausnahmen von dieser Regel
taiwan hat für diese Situation
vorgesorgt es hat sich einen silicon
Shield geschaffen einen Schutzschirm aus
[Musik]
Halbleitern und Deutschland genau dieser
Schutzschirm gegenüber China
fehlt für die Medikamente die Anton
dringend bräuchte gibt es keinen
Schutzschirm keine Alternative zu den
fehlenden
Antibiotika die Behandlung schlägt nicht
an mit einer schweren Lungenentzündung
bringen Antons Eltern ihn ins
Krankenhaus seine Sauerstoffwerte waren
sehr sehr sehr niedrig Anton an sich
ging es sehr schlecht er konnte halt
schlecht atmen schlecht laufen i er
hatte einfach keine Lust auf nichts weil
einfach die Kraft gefehlt
hat wenn du keine Antibiotika bekommst
ist es einfach ja schlecht
Elternteil hat einfach sehr schmerzhaft
weil du einfach dem Kind nicht helfen
kannst weil nichts da ist zum
helfen dabei wurden Antibiotika
Jahrzehnte lang in Deutschland
hergestellt Penizillin etwa wurde ab
1950 in Frankfurt Höchst
produziert schon nach ein paar Jahren so
viel dass von hier aus ganz Deutschland
damit versorgt werden konnte dieses
Medikament wird in den kommenden Jahren
unzähigen deutschen das Leben retten W
überlegt wie viel Penicilline und
cephalusporine bei höchst hergestellt
worden sind nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
bis in dieses Jahrtausend rein und
irgendwann haben die Chinesen dann
gedacht das gefällt uns nicht wir wollen
dass der Markt von uns abhängig ist und
die haben
dampingpreise genommen für ihre
Ausgangsstoffe das heißt die Chinesen
haben dafür gesorgt durch dampingpreise
dass die Herstellungen höchst zumachen
musste ja das höchstgebäude ist heute
ein Industriedenkmal seit 2017 gibt es
keine antibiotikaproduktion mehr weil
alle nur auf den Preis geschaut haben
sicherlich kann man im nachsin sagen es
warar ein strategischer Fehler aber
gleichzeitig war es einfach billiger in
in China zu produzieren da muss man dann
unsere Versicherung fragen wollt ihr
sein seid ihr gewillt für Medikamente
jetzt mehr auszugeben weil wir sie in
Europa oder in Indien oder in in in
Amerika produzieren lassen also im
Grunde und der Preisdruck von
Versicherungsgesellschaft von
Konsumenten hat dazu geführt dass de
facto diese ganzen schwierigen
Produktkategorien nach China abgewandert
sind wie abhängig sich Deutschland so
von China gemacht hat wurde
allerspätestens im Jahr zuvor
klar im Oktober 2016 explodiert in einer
antibiotikafabrik im Osten Chinas ein
Kessel wir hörten ein lauten Knall und
rannten alle nach draußen als ich
rauskam war die Straße voller Menschen
wir sahen meterhohe
Flammen die Firma chilu stellt hier das
Antibiotikum piparacillin her in
Deutschland entsteht sofort einen
Versorgungsmangel bei
piperacillinhaltigen
Produkten china hat es durch seine
dampingpreise geschafft das bestimmte
Antibiotika nur noch in China
hergestellt werden zephalospine etwa
werden nur noch in drei großen Werken
produziert wir schreiben die Firmen an
fast immer heißt es no Interview kein
Interview oder wir werden der Spionage
verdächtigt eine beliebte Formulierung
um lästige Journalistenfragen loszu
werden Ausländer würden China
unterwandern das ganze landkämpfe zur
Zeit gegen Spione über politische Themen
sprechen Sie nicht mit uns zu
sensibel bei Chinas großem
antibiotikaakonzern klingt die
Pressestelle
so wir haben kein Interesse mit
ausländischen Medien zusammenzuarbeiten
wir machen keine externe Kommunikation
mit ausländischen Medien auf
Wiedersehen wir machen uns auf den Weg
zu einem der cephalus porinwerke in der
Provinz shangi chilos Ausfuhren nach
Europa sind im vergangenen Jahr noch mal
deutlich angestiegen um
130%
am Haupteingang der antibiotikafabrik
ein Mitarbeiter der sich bereit erklärt
mit uns zu
sprechen wir stellen Cephalosporin her
unsere Produkte gehen in die ganze Welt
darauf bin ich wirklich
stolz unsere Anwesenheit ist nicht
unbemerkt geblieben Diskussion mit der
Security am Haupteingang Filmen
verboten China versucht andere von sich
abhängig und sich selbst autonom zu
machen die risking auf Chinesisch hat
sogar einen eigenen Namen das System der
zwei Kreisläufe meint um sich im
Handelskrieg zu rüsten will China den
Konsum im eigenen Land anheizen und
seine Abhängigkeit von Exporten
reduzieren ist die risking im Grunde
nicht genau das was China seit vielen
Jahren selbst praktiziert also sich
selbst unabhängiger machen sich von
ausländischen Einflüssen abschotten ist
das nicht die gleiche
Strategie nein das glaube ich nicht seit
1978 hat sich China der Welt geöffnet
und seine Politik und Wirtschaft
reformiert China sieht sich als
unverzichtbaren Teil der Welt es wollte
die Welt
umarmen aber wenn ein Land maximalen
Druck auf China ausübt die Kappeln will
wenn es China den Zugang zu
verren will dann muss China das Richtige
tun also viel investieren um alle
Talente zu mobilisieren es muss
eigenständig werden das ist nicht was
China anfangs wollte das ist wozu die
falsche Politik anderer Länder uns
gezwungen hat China hat keine andere
wahlche riskieren noch mehr ihre
chinainestitionen sind zuletzt deutlich
gestiegen ich glaube dass es noch manche
in der Wirtschaft gibt die sagen wir
gucken dass wir einfach optimale Gewinne
mit China machen aber dass sie nicht
dabei sind auch Risiken zu minimieren
aus Angst abgehängt zu werden steckt
Volkswagen 2,5 Milliarden Euro in ein
Projekt mit Horizon Robotics die
Chinesen sind führend bei
selbstfahrenden Autos wir wollen dem
Kunden das Beste geben was es gibt und
dann nehmen wir eben das Beste was es an
Lösung in den Reg b es ist eine teure
Wette auf die Zukunft darauf dass der
Profit in China funktioniert wie früher
ein VW Käfer er läuft und läuft und
läuft es könnte ein Trugschluss sein wir
werden den chinesischen Markt ersetzen
müssen weil langfristig unsere Konzerne
so in dieser Form in der wir es jetzt
sehen nicht mehr die Rolle spielen
werden die sie die letzten 10 20 Jahre
gespielt haben doch im Gefolge der
großen machen auch die kleinen weiter
wie bisher die Zulieferer Unternehmen
wie die neue zahnradwerk Leipzig GmbH
mit gut 1000
Mitarbeitern Hubertus Barsch hat das
Unternehmen vor über 20 Jahren aufgebaut
vor 8 Jahren kam eine Fabrik in China
dazu Volkswagens Absatzprobleme in China
schlagen auch bei ihm ins Kontor am
besten sind die Zeiten wo der Kopf
nachts nicht arbeitet aber Sie können
mir glauben dass ich relativ selten in
den letzten Jahren zum Schlafen komme
auch in diesem Jahr
seine Firma stellt traditionell Motor
und Getriebeteile her für Verbrenner
jetzt aber sind E-Autos wichtig
besonders in China und die Frage ist
kriegt barch den Übergang hin und was
passiert mit seinem wichtigsten Kunden
mit Volkswagen wird der Konzern weiter
bei barch bestellen auch wenn es selbst
für VW eng wird gerade der Mittelstand
in der Lieferkette für Automobil ist ja
momentan extrem gefordert weg vom
Verbrenner hin zum E-Auto
und da werden sicherlich einige durch
den Rost fallen im Moment hat barch eher
das Gefühl noch einmal davon gekommen zu
sein während der Pandemie sei die
chinesischen Kollegen nur auf dem
Schirm nun kommt er zum ersten Mal
wieder nach tenschen er ist nervös was
wird ihn dort
erwarten 2015 haben wir Bart schon
einmal begleitet die chinafabrik gebaut
für 50 Millionen Euro war damals ganz
neu aus barch hemtasche lugte damals der
Reisepass er pendelte ständig zwischen
zwei Welten es war die Zeit der
chinaeuphorie wir gehören wenigen
Privatleuten da hängt nicht nur Herz
dran sondern da hängt auch ein Stück
unserer Existenz dran ja das heißt auch
China muss auch klappen ja das wird
klappen seit Jahren Bar nun hier
produzieren kein reisepast LT mehr aus
dem Hemd es scheint dass sei China heute
weiter entfernt als damals schon allein
wegen
Corona war eine lange Zeit und
anstrengend und ich bin sehr überrascht
dass wir hier in so guten Zustand
momentan sind und dass die Mitarbeiter
das ganze Team praktisch über die Jahre
alleine diesen Betrieb am Laufen gelalen
haben die Pandemie könnte eine Warnung
sein für die Abhängigkeiten dafür wie es
ist plötzlich abgeschnitten zu sein von
Lieferketten den eigenen
Millioneninvestitionen meine
Einschätzung ist dass die deutschen
Unternehmen die in China tätig
sind wissen müssen dass ihre
Investitionen dort
möglicherweise völlig anders behandelt
werden als in Rechtsstaaten wie in
Europa dass sie enteignet werden können
na ja das ist jedenfalls keine nur
theoretische Möglichkeit
Bar aber will von Risikominimierung von
derisking nichts
wissen es gibt auch
Deindustrialisierung alles was mit D
anfängt geht abwärts wir sind in China
sehr stark organisiert aber unterm
Strich für unser Unternehmen müssen wir
überlegen dass unser Risiko in China auf
deutsch gesagt tragbar bleibt
ja das Risiko tragbar bleibt daran
arbeiten sie in ganz Taiwan der Chef des
Unternehmens Geosat setzt auf
Abschreckung und Rüstung
lordchenfang produziert zivile und
zunehmend auch militärische Drohnen denn
Taiwan rüstet auf muss es auch sagt der
Flugingenieur fudien in Südchina wo die
Chinesen ihre Raketen stationiert haben
liegt nur zwei Flugstunden
entfernt
seit dem Besuch der Sprecherin des
usreäsentantenhauses Pelosi im letzten
Jahr sind Chinas raketenstellungen nach
vorne gerückt bisher konnten sie nur den
östlichen Teil Taiwans erreichen jetzt
aber deckt ihre Reichweite jeden
Quadratzentimeter von Taiwans
Territorium
ab um ihre Maschinen im Kampf
auszuprobieren gibt es seit Februar
2022 trauriges Testfeld die Ukraine eine
von GEOS Helikopter Drohnen soll schon
bald dorthineschickt werden lengling
wird sie
begleiten die drohen können ganz normal
fliegen und dabei Fotos machen sie
können ein großes Gebiet abfotografieren
und automatisch zurückkehren oder man
kann eine Route festlegen sass sie an
bestimmten Orten etwas zu essen oder zu
trinken etwas Treibstoff oder Vorräte
abwerfen
die Drohne kann natürlich auch anderes
abwerfen lie changling weiß was an der
ukrainischen Front gebraucht wird denn
er war schon da gleich nach
Kriegsausbruch hat er seinen Job als
uberdriver aufgegeben und ist
losgefahren der ehemalige französische
Fremdenlegionär wollte mal wieder was
erleben die Ironie der Globalisierung
der Taiwaner Lee flog chinesische drohen
an der ukrainischen Front und wurde bei
seiner Rückkehr sofort von Geosat
angeheuert nun wird er eine Spende in
die Ukraine
[Musik]
bringen es gibt viele junge Menschen in
Taiwan die als internationale
Freiwillige in die Ukraine gegangen sind
das war sehr mutig die langfristige
Entwicklung aber ist wichtiger mit
anderen Worten was können wir vom
ukrainischen Schlachtfeld len Wendung
der Drohnen angeht sie ist ein modernes
und dringend notwendiges Instrument auf
dem Schlachtfeld wenn es gelingt sie in
vollem Umfang in die bestehenden
Truppenteile zu integrieren wir müssen
diese neue Technik der Kriegsführung
studieren und auch in Taiwan
einführen Wohltätigkeit gepaart mit
nüchternem Kalkül soll der kleinen
asiatischen Demokratie helfen sich gegen
ihren totalitären Nachbarn zur weh zu
setzen um das Risiko eines Angriffs zu
verringern sein eigenes Risiko versucht
China gezielt zu verringern es sieht
sich im globalen Wettstreit mit den
USA im Zentrum von Pekings Strategie die
Vorherrschaft bei bestimmten besonders
wertvollen Rohstoffen Provinz jünan
Südwesten Chinas unser Ziel ist eine
Miene der Firma junanong sie liefert
knapp ein Drittel der weltweiten
Produktion von um das Firmenvideo klotzt
mit
Erfolgsmeldungen Germanium und Gallium
sind extrem wichtige Metalle für die
Herstellung von
Halbleitern Deutschland ist erpressbar
weil es sich auch bei seltenen Metallen
abhängig gemacht hat gut die Hälfte
seines galliums kommt aus China bei
Germanium sind das ganze
82% seit August hat China ihre Ausfuhr
beschränkt es ist eine Vergeltung für
ushelssanktionen aber es trifft auch
Deutschland im August gingen die
Ausfuhren von Germanium und Gallium aus
China auf
Null china könnte jederzeit in einigen
Produkten den HEN abdrehen und dann
sagen dann kriegt ihr eben jetzt keine
Germanium oder Gallium das war jetzt nur
eine Ankündigung dass man da Zertifikate
braucht das war ja kein Bann
da müss da muss man von lernen da muss
man sehen wo das passieren könnte bis zu
2 km tief gehen die Stollen der miine in
jünnen auf unsere Interviewanfrage hat
ung nicht reagiert am Haupteingang
Stacheldraht und ein Warnschild strenges
Zutrittsverbot für fremde Personen und
Fahrzeuge sofort stellt uns ein Wachmann
zur Rede wir fragen noch mal nach einem
Interview ich muss die zentrale Fragen
die entscheiden ob sie rein können jetzt
dürfen sie nicht
rein die Stimmung ist angespannt dem
Wachmann ist unser plötzliches
Auftauchen sichtlich
unangenehm das Unternehmen nicht mit uns
reden auch von staatlichen Stellen nur
Absagen allein Viktor GA Vizepräsident
des Center for China and globalization
und inoffizielles Sprachrohr der
Kommunistischen Partei ist zum Interview
bereit china hat die absolute Dominanz
bei seltenen Erden und Metallen china
hat noch zwei Dutzend Asse im Ärmel wir
haben kein Problem mit
Deutschland Republik den USA bei ihren
ungerechtfertigten Sanktionen gegen
China nachfolgt dann werden Exporte nach
Deutschland genauso reguliert wie die
chinesische Regierung das für die beiden
Metalle Gallium und Germanium jetzt
schon
macht
ge wie bei Antibiotika gab es auch bei
Gallium eine eigene Produktion in
Deutschland hier in Stade bei
Hamburg
aber nur bis
2017 galiium aus Stade war nicht
wettbewerbsfähig und dann ist die
politische Frage ist es mir wert auch in
Deutschland Gallium herzustellen mit
Blick auf Versorgungssicherheit mit
Blick auf
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit für die
Halbleiterindustrie scheint diese Frage
beantwortet ein auf die
Zukunft im Mai 2023 vollführen EU
kommissionspräsidentin und Kanzler bei
infinien in Dresden einen digitalen
spartenstich für ein neues
Halbleiterwerk Halbleiter werden oft als
das Erdöl des 21 jahrhunderts bezeichnet
der eine Rohstoff sozusagen von dem fast
alles andere abhängt bis 2030 wollen wir
gemeinsam mit der Industrie Europa
Anteil an der weltweiten chipsproduktion
verdoppeln auf 20% und weil der
chipsmarkt sich so rasant entwickelt
heißt das für uns eigentlich dass wir
unsere heutigen Kapazitäten
vervierfachen
müssen 33 Milliarden Euro Subventionen
macht die EU dafür locker unter diesen
Bedingungen ist der Standort Dresden
auch für TSMC attraktiv ein nar der
denkt dass Taiwans wichtigstes
Unternehmen bei sol invtien tun und
lassen kann was es will früher hat die
SMC viel in china investiert das ist
vorbei denn die Halbleiterindustrie ist
Teil der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie wir machen uns
große Gedanken über die wirtschaftliche
Sicherheit des
halbleiterdesigns wir respektieren die
globale Aufstellung des Unternehmens
aber es muss garantiert sein dass
Taiwans Vorsprung in dieser Industrie
erhalten bleibt
das heiß die modernsten
Produktionsabläufe und die Forschung
müssen in Taiwan
bleiben die jüngsten Investitionen von
TSMC gingen alle in Eng Verbündete
Länder ist das ein
Zufall nein es ist kein Zufall das heißt
wir sind zwar mit der Entwicklung eines
globalen Netzwerks einverstanden aber
zum Schutz der Lieferkette geht TSMC nur
in Länder mit ähnlichen
Werten
Industriepolitik dort und hier auf
dieser grünen Wiese in Dresden wird t
smmc in etwa 4 Jahren Chips fertigen
nicht die modernsten deren Produktion in
Taiwan bleiben soll sondern frühere
Generationen wie sie die europäische
Automobilindustrie braucht 10 Milliarden
Euro wollen die Taiwaner investieren
etwa die Hälfte davon sollen sie
subventioniert bekommen ist das für
Deutschland gut angelegtes Geld
in meinen Augen lügt man sich hier
teilweise ein bisschen in die Tasche der
Impakt auf die weltweite Industrie wird
sich durch die Maßnahmen die wir derzeit
in Europa sehen in den nächsten 10
Jahren nicht fundamental
ändern wenn wir bis 2030 nur sechs
zusätzliche Fabriken in Europa haben
wird das nicht ausreichen um die von
vonder derlin versprochenen 20% zu
erreichen denn gleichzeitig entstehen ja
auch in China Taiwan Kore Japan und in
den USA neue
Fabriken wir sollten deshalb die 20%
vergessen und uns darauf konzentrieren
dass unsere Herstellung europäischer
[Musik]
wird eine Kritik die der zuständige
Bundeswirtschaftsminister so nicht
gelten lassen will erstens muss man
irgendwo anfangen na Halbleiter werden
in Zukunft überall sein wir sind gut
beraten ein Teil jedenfalls dessen was
wir verbrauchen selber
herzustellen und so manchmal verstehe
ich es auch nicht also es gibt ein eine
große Sorge um die Attraktivität des
Industriestandorts Deutschlands und dann
kommen solche Unternehmen und bauen die
Leitindustrie oder wollen die
Leitindustrie der nächsten Jahrzehnte
hier aufbauen und dann dann wird das
auch
kritisiert Deutschland versucht
zumindest etwas autonomer zu werden
längst aber steckt chinesische Hightech
im Zentrum unserer Kommunikation
betreibt die deutschen Mobilfunknetze
kritische
Infrastruktur wie viel Konflikt wagt
Berlin um auch dieses Risiko zu
verringern das ist vielleicht auch der
logische Fehler unserer die risking
Diskussion gerade denn sie hat den
Anschein dass sie etwas ganz friedliches
ist wir müssen nur ein bisschen die
Risken kleines bisschen das Risiko
minimieren ein bisschen diversifizieren
als würde das die chinesische Führung
nicht merken und als hätte sie nicht
durchaus ein Interesse daran dass das
Gegenteil passiert denn China möchte
nicht die risk werden das heißt wir
müssen wirklich durchdeklinieren wo sind
wir abhängig wo finden wir andere
Partner um Alternativen zu haben aber
nicht jetzt um zu sagen wir kaufen dann
nichts mehr von China sondern um den
Chinesen sagen zu können ihr könnt uns
nicht
erpressen die Skyline der Hightech
Metropole sch ist in Sichtweite wenn man
in der Huawei Linie 1 durch das Retorten
Europa fährt dass der konzerngründer als
firmenkampus bauen ließ von einer
Haltestelle zur nächsten bummelt man von
Paris über Bologna und Oxford nach Rom
oder
Heidelberg selten bekommen westliche
Medien hier Einblicke wir wurden
eingeladen zu einer exklusiven Tour hier
sind wir jetzt in Heidelberg und das ist
ein fahrerloses Auto extra für
Sie
autonom und futuristisch geht es durch
die Kopie von Heidelbergs romantischen
Gassen über Brücken vorbei an Flüssen
und kleinen
Seen ein Märchenland so scheint es mit
hoher
Symbolkraft sie sollen das Symbol für
Chinas Widerstandskraft sein schwarze
Schwäne dem Aberglauben nach und auch in
Huas Firmengeschichte stehen sie für ein
unvorhersehbares Ereignis das
schwerwiegende Folgen haben K
Huawei sagt Unglück und Bedrohung habe
sie noch stärker gemacht deshalb werden
die schwarzen Schwäne hier auf dem
firmenkampus liebevoll gefüttert und
gepflegt die Tiere sollen die
Belegschaft jeden Tag daran erinnern auf
das Unvorhersehbare vorbereitet zu
sein
charmoffensive mit Privatführung Lunch
und Carsten sensz er ist huawes Sprecher
für Deutschland arbeitet eigentlich in
K customers D ich weiß SAS HT sich immer
so ein bisschen an wie Marketingspruch
ist es aber nicht Huawei
selbstvermarktungsoffensive zielt auf
die Bundesregierung ab denn wieder steht
ein schwarzer Schwan im
Raum Berlin sieh huawe 5g Technik ein
Sicherheitsrisiko undchtet Ch SH
Software installieren und Deutschland
per Fernwartung ausspionieren lassen
vielleicht sogar Netze und wichtige
Infrastruktur abschalten Huawei
bestreitet das wir als Ausrüster haben
keinen Zugriff keinen Fernzugriff auf
Daten in Mobilfunknetzen noch auf die
Steuerung von
Mobilfunknetzen diese Netze befinden
sich unter der Kontrolle der
Netzbetreiber diese Szenarien von
Spionage und auch Sabot
gehören eher ins Reich von Science
Fiction doch die Science Fiction so die
Befürchtung könnte Realität werden
Chinas nationales Sicherheitsgesetz
verpflichtet Unternehmen zur Auskunft
gegenüber Partei und Staat in den USA
sind Huawei Komponenten deshalb längst
Tabu ein Verbot der chinesischen 5g
Technik für deutsche Netzbetreiber es
hätte Signalwirkung für ganz
Europa
wenn sich die deutsche Regierung selbst
ins Knie schießen will bitte wir können
euch nicht stoppen wissen Sie wir können
die Leute nicht davon abhalten all die
dummen Dinge zu tun die dem deutschen
Volk all die Schäden Verletzungen und
Verluste zufügen werden ich hoffe aber
persönlich dass die deutsche Regierung
so wie ich sie immer wahrgenommen habe
klüger und Weiser sein
wird ein Verbot der chinesischen 5g
Technik für deutsche Netzbetreiber es
hätte Signalwirkung für ganz Europa
wir wollen kein Land als Kunden
verlieren schon gar nicht den größten
Markt Europas den deutschen Markt denn
wenn man auf dem deutschen Markt
überleben und sich behaupten kann dann
kann man das auch auf vielen anderen
Märkten auch die deutschen
Telefonanbieter laufen Sturm gegen
mögliche Einschränkungen drohen Berlin
mit
Schadenersatzklagen trotz aller
Sicherheitsbedenken wie die Autokonzerne
wollen sie in Sachen China so
weitermachen wie bisher der Druck auf
die Politik ist enorm ich habe für mich
immer sehr klar gemacht dass zu
Risikominimierung auch gehört dass wir
keine Technologie von China hier in
unsere Infrastruktur verbauen dürfen mit
der wir verletzlich sind und ich finde
da müssen wir auch selbstbewusst genug
sein und sagen wir lassen uns da von
niemandem unter Druck
setzen offenbar doch Deutschland
versucht einen Kompromiss die risking
light sozusagen es wir erstmal nur ein
kleiner aber wesentlicher Teil der
Huawei Technik verboten und von China
mehr Transparenz
gefordert aber auch bei unserem
stundenlangen Besuch im kulisseneuropa
von Huawei haben wir von Chinas megatech
Konzern nur die Fassaden
gesehen in Taiwan freut man sich über
alles was eine wachsende Distanz zu
China verrät es macht Hoffnung dass
Deutschland sich im
ksequent auf die Seite des
demokratischen Taiwan stellen
würde wir würden uns wünschen dass
Deutschland bereit ist seine
Kriegsschiffe im asiatischpazifischen
Raum
einzusetzen und Militärübungen im
indopazifischen Raum
durchzuführen doch wer weiß ob die
internationale Hilfe wirklich
kommt für den Frieden vonw wichtig dass
die taiwanesische politische Führung
Peking davon überzeugen kann dass die
Gesellschaft einem Angriff standhalten
kann denn wenn der Eindruck entsteht
dass die taiwanesische Gesellschaft sehr
schnell kapitulieren wird erhöht sich
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Angriffs
sehr
stark sie vertrauen nicht darauf treffen
sich einmal die Woche mit militärischer
Disziplin auf der Freilichtbühne des da
an Parks in
taip was wir hoffen ist den Willen
demonstrieren könen uns zu wehren wir
können nicht von anderen Ländern
erwarten dass Sie uns helfen wenn wir
nicht den Willen zeigen er selbst zu
tun also üben sie entschieden auch ein
bisschen rührend den
Nahkampf die holzgewehre haben sie heute
vergessen aber das bremst den Eifer
nicht selbstverteidigungsgruppen wie
diese gibt es inzwischen im ganzen Land
gerade die jungen Taiwaner finden keine
Bindung an die Volksrepublik und wollen
sich vorbereiten auf den
Ernstfall wenn die Katastrophe erstmal
da ist werden wir alle nervös sein und
vielleicht vergessen haben was wir schon
mal
wussten aber durch ständiges Üben geht
die Bewegung in das Gedächtnis der
Muskeln über und dann können wir
Entscheidungen treffen die unser eigenes
Leben und vielleicht sogar das unserer
Familienmitglieder
retten
heute ist ihr
starrgast der Mann der im vergangenen
Jahr in der Ukraine gekämpft hat macht
nun tapfer mit beim
Krafttraining eigentlich aber ist er
gekommen um sein ukrainisches erste
hilfeset
vorzuführen ja das ist ein
Verband ja ja wenn man ein Loch hier
vorne hat und ein
hinten s gebannt das worauf sie
trainieren rückt durch ihn noch einmal
näher er ist wirklich in die Ukraine
gegangen und lebendig zurückgekehrt das
ist sehr
bewunderungswürdig ich habe die Sachen
die er heute mitgebracht hat früher
schon gesehen aber heute habe ich zum
ersten mal kapiert dass sie wirklich in
einem Krieg benutzt
wurden am Ende eines langen
trainingsabends ist der Held emotional
[Musik]
aufgewühlt was er singt ist die Hymne
der
[Musik]
Ukraine
ob China Taiwan wirklich angreift das
wissen wir nicht aber Taiwan versucht
sich darauf vorzubereiten und
Deutschland das was wir in Deutschland
tun müssen ist dass wir uns unabhängiger
machen und dass wir uns auch
selbstbewusst gegenüber China aufstellen
und ich glaube am Ende hilft das auch um
me besseren Umgang mit China zu haben
weniger abhängig weniger verwundbar zu
sein das wird teuer wir müssen diese
Grundversorgung unserer Bevölkerung aus
eigener Kraft wieder leisten können wir
müssen sicherlich auch weit
diversifizieren damit wir eben nicht
solche Länderrisiken politisch
akzeptieren müssen aber Deutschland ist
China nicht
ausgeliefert China braucht Europa auch
es ist wir sind abhängig bei einigen
Produkten aber China braucht den Markt
Europa auch und China braucht auch
Importe aus Europa
in Berlin sind Anton und sein Vater noch
einmal beim
Arzt
Famil die Therapie im Krankenhaus hat
Anton
geholfen seine Lunge ist wieder
gesund ich bin natürlich heilfoh dass
das nicht anders ausgegangen ist aber
man
möchte nicht noch mal in so Situation
geraten und dann entsteht auch Frust und
Wut muss man sagen dass sit überhaupt
kommt erinnerst du dich noch daran wie
das war für dich als du ins Krankenhaus
musstest ja sogar auch in der Nacht
einmal wei ja da wollte ich eigentlich
nicht ins krankenhf wie geht dir heute
gut bei Anton ist die Sache noch einmal
glimpflig
[Musik]
verlaufen die seine Patienten nicht ganz
aufgebraucht und ihm gegeben haben
vielleicht hat er dann noch etwas in der
Schublade wenn es mal wieder knapp wird
das ist jetzt natürlich aus der Not
geboren theoretisch dürfen wir das ja
gar nicht aber wir machen es einfach
trotzdem weil aktuell immer wieder
Situation kommt das Patienten an dem Tag
die Therapie nicht beginnen können weil
sie warten müssen zwei bis di Tage bis
das Medikament dann lieferbar ist die
eigene Erpressbarkeit merkt man oft das
dann wenn Dinge passieren wie bei Anton
wenn eine unübersichtliche verstörende
Welt eingreift in das Leben eines
sechsjährigen Abhängigkeit aber ist
nicht schicksalhaftes sie ist gemacht
und deshalb kann sie auch wieder
verringert werden wenn man
will
[Musik]